Ezra loves gardening.
Each sunflower plant that he watered,
needs 0.7 liters of water,
and every lily which he watered,
it needs 0.5 liters of water.
Ezra has a total of 11 liters of water for its plants.
The following inequality
S represents the number of sunflowers,
and L represents the number of lilies,
which Ezra can pour.
Let's see if there's any logic in it.
It seems that...
The number of sunflowers is S
and he must use 7/10 of a liter of plant.
So this first member here is here
is how much water is used
for irrigation of sunflowers.
The second article is how much water
is used for watering lilies,
because he needs half a liter for a lily.
And he has a total of 11 liters.
So the sum up here
must be less than or equal to 11.
All right.
Ezra watered 10 lilies.
So L equals 10.
How many sunflowers can he most pour
with the remaining amount of water?
Let's think a little about this.
We have 0.7 on the number of sunflowers he wares.
Plus ...
Let L assume that L equals 10.
He watered 10 lilies
and each uses half a liter.
So 0.5 by 10 will be 5.
We'll have 5 liters of watering 10 lilies.
And this must be less than or equal to 11.
We may try to separate S on the left side.
Let's do it. The number of sunflowers.
We can first pull out 5 on both sides.
We remove 5 from both sides.
And we will stay on the left side
only by 0.7 on S.
This expression is the total amount of water,
which he will use for sunflowers,
which must be less than or equal to ...
11 minus 5 is equal to 6.
And now we can divide both sides to 0.7.
By not having to change inequality,
because we divide to a positive number of 0.7.
We will get S ...
S is less than or equal to
6 divided by 0.7.
Or we can even write it like ...
we can write it like ...
This is 6 divided by 0.7.
Let me write everything like a liver.
This is the same as 6, divided by 7/10,
which is equal to 6 in 10 on 7,
which is equal to 60/7
which is equal to ... how much is that?
8 and 4/7.
So S should be less than 8 and 4/7.
Now, assuming that he ...
we only think about whole plants ...
i. with integers, these are actually whole plants.
So if S should be less than 8 and 4/7,
how much sunflower he can best pour
with the remaining amount of water?
It can spawn at most 8 plants.
We will assume that it can not be poured
only part of a plant.
He either watered something or did not watery it.
So he will spawn 8 plants.
Because this is the largest integer,
which is less than 8 and 4/7.
That suits ...
I have to say that this is less than or equal to 8 and 4/7.